first of all gentlemen I guess my main
thing is so I love the boys I loved good
boys have you ever seen our voice no but
it's an HBO miniseries I think and I've
heard it also has the word boys in it so
it must be do that I was gonna ask you
what's the next thing you guys are
producing boys just boy just boy about a
boys we're doing about yeah no we've
done all the boys things we ever should
have the fact they both materialized at
the same time is truly miraculous
considering how long both these things
have been just a it's been confusing at
the company oh yeah it's confusing for
us so we'll think there's a meeting for
one thing and the other you don't like
it completely um listen I've been very
impressed with you guys as producers you
you really have made stuff that I
genuinely love what is the secret to
being good producers because you guys
you know especially for good boys um I
think hiring people that you can rely on
that ultimately understand you know your
sensibilities and themselves have strong
creative sensibilities is very important
um you know also not all the time but a
lot of the time and good boys is one of
the examples you find someone who like
should have had this opportunity earlier
in life and it's just ready for it yeah
like the directors of this movie were
just ready to direct a movie they've
been ready for a while and it's nice
like teaming up with someone who's about
to have like a moment where they go from
one place to another yeah and I'd like a
good energy and I think making things
that we genuinely would watch is it's
very important as well like you know we
were like the boys we were huge fans of
the comic we read it from the first
issue it came out so it was an easy
thing to understand how to bring to life
and you know this movie
I've known Lee and Jean for a really
long time and like it had a lot of
similar themes to work we've done but
also felt like it was exploring a whole
new area and a new
and new kind of emotional stresses that
were kind of you know not or what we had
done before but in but felt like we
could elevate it still yeah I think it
becomes pretty clear like yeah we could
help make that better you know are you
fully prepared for the phone calls
you're gonna get from the three kids in
this movie and about forward of five
years when they say I cannot believe you
asked me to do that I'm sure have they
seen it I'm sure they've actually
learned it by now yeah they know their
tummy and think about when you were 12
like that's like I think people like you
listen to them talk about themselves for
five anyway it's crazy crazy are you
whatever movie they're like a little
exaggerated how innocent they are I
think to real-life yeah honestly I think
they know much more than they do these
kids they have the unit he didn't have
he has in their pockets I just think
about that
it's crazy with this film was there
anything I'm always fascinated about
deleted scenes and what didn't make the
final cut was there anything in the
script or in pre-production that ended
up not happening or anything you removed
and for whatever reason there was a
pretty big element in the original
version where the kids were like a
singing group like they all sang
together and there was like a few
musical sequences and that was one of
the bigger debates we had making the
film is just like does that make sense
does it not and in the end we made it
the only Thor is into singing and that
too a kind of alienate a but we did
shoot like a giant musical sequence of
the kids like singing in a mall yeah
there was a point where like in order to
try to get money they like busk in the
mall basically by singing and yeah it
didn't quite make sense just for the
characters but it was took a long time
to shoot was very expensive yes exactly
so as I said at the beginning of this
thing I absolutely loved the first
season of the boys and I know you guys
are currently filming the second season
yeah what can you it's first of all
Congrats on getting a second season
before the first season even came out
yeah that shows how expensive the show
is yeah our whole thing within enough
money would be just half they have to
keep going yeah they're just like we
can't stop we look stupid at this point
yeah what Amazon don't worry okay but
being serious what did you tease people
about the second season and with the
success of the first season they put out
a press release saying how popular it is
do you are you already thinking wow
maybe we are gonna go even bigger in the
third yes they yeah they already have
more resources for the second season and
they are adding more characters and they
are the scope of the show organically
grows as the show continues and we just
watched actually the first episode of
the second season this week and we were
all it was a wonderful thing as
producers we were like this is way
better than I ever could have hoped it
was going to be yeah I mean it just like
looks a bit better feels bigger the
actors all know what they're doing it's
just it was it was exciting and I think
with the show like the boys especially
where the tone is so unique like for the
actors to be able to watch the show and
to see like oh that's that's what it is
it allows them to come back with just
like completely locked into it you know